[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre sur tv soixante
dix huit pour un nouvel entretien
politique et deux invités aujourd'hui
pierre l'unique héritière bonjour à tous
les deux est bienvenu en plateau anciens
et nouveaux référents la république en
marche dans le ed département pierre lux
vous étiez en poste depuis trois ans
depuis 2019 quel bilan déjà brièvement
vous faites de votre de votre action
écoutez les gars c'est un bilan rempli
de s'attendre de fierté d'avoir réussi à
structurer le départ de mouvement dans
le département on a une cinquantaine de
comités locaux
treize mille adhérents un nombre qui n'a
fait que croître depuis 2010 cette
preuve s'il en est que l'espoir
politique qu'on apporte en 2017 on le
porte toujours les gens y adhèrent et
aussi la fierté d'avoir mené à bien
mobilisation de nos militants pendant
quatre scrutin des européennes en 2019
les municipales départementales
régionales qui a renforcé notre ancrage
dans le territoire avec maintenant plus
de 250 élus si mr nouveau merck ont été
élus les autres tenues en 2020 donc
c'est un peu tout ça le bilan du quelles
que soient ses pionniers des élections
municipales départementales régionales
et même une législative partielle dans
la 12e circonscription laquelle vous
avez participé et où le succès ne nous a
pas toujours souri non plus puisque
cette 11e circonscription finalement
vous l'avez perdu aussi est ce que tout
ça c'est cet inquiétant dans l'optique
des prochaines élections aussi dont je
suis pas inquiet vis-à-vis de sa vie
c'est la vie politique aussi de gagner
les élections d'en perdre une élection
partielle en cours de mandat est
toujours une élection difficile des
élections locales pour un mouvement
jeunes sont elles aussi toujours un défi
à relever donc seulement pas plus
inquiet que cela pour les écrits il ya
d'autres élections à venir et ce sera
votre rôle maintenant en tant que
nouveau référent la république en marche
au département la principale mission ce
sera de conserver ses postes de députée
tout en pensant déjà pour l'instant à la
présidentielle
d'avoir effectivement une première
échéance c'est l'échéance présidentielle
celle qui va nous occuper dans les trois
prochains mois on est déjà tourné vers
cet objectif nos militants sont déjà
mobilisés pierre l'a dit c'est
finalement un héritage que je vais
devoir porter celui de continuer à faire
en sorte que des militants la république
en marche mais également ceux de la
majorité présidentielle qui nous
rejoignent pour cette élection
présidentielle puisse se tourner vers un
seul objectif celui de la réduction je
l'espère d' emmanuel macron si il
annoncé rapidement sa candidature le but
ce sera aussi de fédérer les différentes
formations partenaires de la république
en mars ce cancer votre allié du modem
déjà depuis depuis la précédente
élection mais aussi de nouvelles
formations je pense à horizon par
exemple fondé par edouard philippe
représenté dans l'ouest parisien par
arnaud péricard il faudra aussi leur
laisser un peu de place comment vous
allez composer cette nouvelle majorité
plurielle vous savez cette recomposition
elle est déjà en place là où certains
partis politiques se désunissent il ya
on voit bien ses mouvements tectoniques
entre hal et leur zemmour et le
rassemblement national nous on a joué la
carte du rassemblement depuis déjà
quelques quelques semaines quelques mois
et on est déjà en plus en position de
continuer à à convaincre les français
que le
projet comporte et le meilleur est à ce
titre effectivement des personnalités
comme un os péricard nous ont rejoints
via horizons mais je pense aussi à karl
olive qui n'est pas rentré dans la
casbah parti mais qui va potentiellement
faire cette campagne avec nous parler de
d'horizon il ya eu quand même une prise
de distance aussi d'edouard philippe la
maison commune aujourd'hui les bases
sont presque fragile alors c'est aussi
le principe des fondations d'un
mouvement d'un mouvement qui est celui
de la majorité présidentielle à travers
un simple citoyen on voit bien que
edward fille par ray a pas apporté de
nouveau son soutien à la
la candidature d'emmanuel macron et moi
je suis persuadé qu'on arrivera à faire
de très grandes choses ensemble nous
sommes déjà parti sur de bons rails on
va prendre le temps de vous présenter
aussi vous êtes le nouveau référent donc
lrm dans les yvelines adjoint au maire
de conflans-sainte-honorine pardon
marcheurs de la première heure aussi
pourquoi si on revient sur votre
engagement oui effectivement c'était
pour moi un quasiment un primo
engagement celui de dents marche en 2016
j'ai très vite adhéré aux idées un peu
disruptive d'emmanuel macron j'ai donc
fondé le un des tout premiers comités
locaux des yvelines du nord yvelines en
tout cas à conflans sainte honorine et
cet engagement à continuer pour aller
jusque effectivement
travailler sur un projet municipal j'ai
donc rejoint la liste de laurent bros et
je suis donc devenu son adjoint en
charge de la sécurité de la prévention
on a continué à travailler au niveau
politique départementale puisque j'ai
aussi été candidat aux élections
régionales on entre en troisième
position dans la liste de laurent saint
martin vous avez le sentiment qu
emmanuel macron a rempli sa mission
puisque vous êtes engagés de la première
heure quel regard vous portez sur son
bilan après cinq ans moi je considère
que c'est un bilan très positif il a
fait énormément de choses pour le
quotidien des français je pense que
l'histoire va lui rendre raison très
rapidement d'un cadre de cette nouvelle
élection on voit ce qui a été fait pour
mieux protéger les français à travers
des vraies réformes sur le plan social
on a des vrais résultats son plan
économique je pense notamment à cette
baisse du chômage à l'attractivité de la
france qui devient de nouveau le pays le
plus attractif d'europe mais évidemment
il reste beaucoup à faire on a été très
impacté premièrement par la crise des
gilet jaune mais aussi par cette crise
sanitaire terrible qui nous concerne
tous j'espère qu'elle sera bientôt
derrière nous et que le plan de
transformation qui avait auguré emmanuel
macron pourra continuer sur les cinq ans
à venir et quelques ombres au tableau
malgré tout je pense à la question de
l'environnement par exemple avec le
tribunal administratif de paris qui a
reconnu l'état coupable d'inaction
climatique et l'existence aussi d'un
préjudice écologique
il ya aussi cette question de la
sécurité les derniers sondages montrent
que sur la question sécuritaire le bilan
du président est pas forcément
apprécié elles sont des deux axes
importants de campagne oui ce seront
deux axes primordiaux c'est une évidence
vous parlez de deux sujets que je
connais bien parce que je travaille dans
les énergies renouvelables et je suis
adjoint délégué à la sécurité pour ce
qui est de la transition écologique
beaucoup de choses ont déjà été faites
par emmanuel macron et parle par son
gouvernement je pense notamment à la aux
héros plastique à plusieurs initiatives
mais c'est une stratégie des petits pas
malheureusement il ya beaucoup de choses
à faire pour réussir à faire évoluer le
monde dans lequel on vit mais si on
prend notamment le plan france ô france
relance qui a largement contribué déjà
faire agir nos entreprises on voit déjà
des premiers résultats notamment avec un
plan à hydrogène qui a été annoncée
récemment et qui pour moi est un est une
énergie d'avenir pour ce qui est de la
sécurité
on a remis du monde sur le terrain là je
le constate réellement en tant
qu'adjoint au maire de prendre cette
casquette quelques secondes pour vous
dire que finalement ce qu'on a ce qui a
été détricoté pendant plusieurs années
par les gouvernements successifs
emmanuel macron a essayé de revenir à
une situation positive on se retrouve
avec plus de monde sur le terrain on se
retrouve avec des affaires de plus en
plus élucidées et les je suis sûr que
les français vont reconnaître mais ce
regard vous portez même regard sur le
sur le bilan des manuels meilleur jeu
apportera un complément parlons sur la
sécurité il est question mais qu'elle
l'a bien dit de plus d'effectifs et de
plus d'effectifs sur le terrain mais
aussi de moyens plus adaptés
pendant longtemps la police l'accord
hameury les forces de sécurité n'ont pas
bénéficié des investissements qui
étaient nécessaires pour les maintenir à
un haut niveau de l'efficacité d'une
part mais aussi de de confort sol dans
les conditions de travail que ce sera
sur le l'équipement vestimentaire sur
les moyens de défendre ses moyens de
transport tous ces sujets ont fait
l'objet de très forts d'investissement
depuis 2007 et qui vont continuer sur la
partie climatiques là aussi même qu'elle
parlait des petits pas et aussi les
grands pas qui se prépare je pense
notamment au plan france 2030 qui a été
présenté par le président il ya quelques
mois qui annoncent de très grands
d'investissement sur l'énergie notamment
avec la construction de nouveaux
réacteurs nucléaires mais aussi sur un
verdissement de l'industrie parce que il
faut à la fois réindustrialiser la
france c'est important et ça a commencé
on voit que
plusieurs gros gros investissement
industriel qui ont été annoncées la
semaine dernière mais il faut que cette
industrialisation se fasse aussi avec en
tête toujours
la nécessité d'un développement
économique durable et donc d'une école
d'une économie d'une industrie sauf que
respectueuse de l'environnement sur la
question de la sécurité vous parlez de
ces moyens supplémentaires on sent une
forte tension dans la société française
aujourd'hui c'est une forte division
aussi et comment répondre à ces attentes
laquelle réponse peut apporter votre
futur candidat président il faut se
souvenir qu'en 2017 quand même une macro
est arrivé au pouvoir on était encore
dans une situation d'état d'urgence
sécuritaire
suite au dramatique attentat des années
de 2015 2016 il faut voir quel chemin a
été parcouru aussi la situation
sécuritaire est imparfaite mais elle
s'améliore aussi grâce à l'action des
services de renseignement qui ont été
bien mieux dotées pendant le quinquennat
d'une stratégie aussi en termes
diplomatiques et sécuritaires à
l'international qui a permis de mettre
fin
à la présence importante de l'état
islamique dans certains pays au
moyen-orient donc tout ça c'est un tout
on peut pas simplement se baser sur les
chiffres pris très spécifiquement de
certains l'augmentation de certains
délits ou crimes alors que d'une manière
générale
on sent cette tension dans la société
vous devez la sentir vous en tant qu'élu
aussi sur le lien vous la santé oui bien
entendu surtout si vous êtes en charge
des questions sécuritaires exactement
sur ce que je vais appeler la sécurité
du quotidien ces petites incivilités qui
pourrissent le quotidien des français il
ya aussi une vraie réponse à apporter
j'ai déjà entendu notamment notre
ministre darmanin parler de renforcer
finalement les prérogatives de la police
municipale c'est ce qui va aussi à mon
avis contribuer à rétablir ce lien entre
les forces de police en général et des
citoyens pour pour conclure cette cet
entretien comment va s'organiser la
campagne dans les prochains mois déjà
pour la présidentielle ensuite pour les
législatives pour pour l hérault m
nous sommes déjà on était par exemple
sur le terrain la semaine dernière nous
avons réalisé plus de 25 opérations sur
le terrain des opérations qui consistait
notamment à défendre les couleurs de
l'europe et la présidence française du
conseil de l'union européenne et cette
campagne va se poursuivre on va déjà
travaillé sur un appel à la lutte contre
l'abstention c'est un vrai sujet de
démocratie et on va commencer on va
commencer avec ce sujet là et très
rapidement évidemment on va se mettre en
ordre de marche sans faire de mauvais
jeu de mots pour aller convaincre les
français du sérieux du projet d'
emmanuel macron ce serait une
organisation évidemment par
circonscription qui pourra permettre
très rapidement d'aller vers les
législatives après cette campagne
présidentielle et on utilisera aussi
évidemment les forces vives que nous
avons à travers les élus c est lui qui
nous rejoignent qui sont pas forcément
encartés dans un parti mais qui sont
favorables à l'action des manuels macron
et elles ce sont des très bons relais et
une bonne oreille près des français pour
obtenir plus d'informations sur leur
quotidien sur ce qu'ils souhaitent faire
et comment on peut avancer sur ce projet
de transformation pour les législatives
pour les douze circonscriptions les
candidats ne seront officiellement
désigné qu'une fois la présidentielle
terminée oui exactement on a un premier
combat qui est celui de l'élection
présidentielle et on est tous tournés
vers cet objectif ceci dit évidemment se
préparent aussi pour les chances d'après
les chances d'après elle se prépare
notamment avec les députés déjà en place
elle se prépare avec les partenaires de
la majorité présidentielle et nous
pourrons discuter tous ensemble des
meilleurs choix pour obtenir les
meilleurs candidats possibles et
transformer l'essai en donnant une
majorité à l'assemblée nationale un
rapport de forces au final lors de
l'élection présidentielle aussi on l'a
bien compris pour voir ensuite et et
faire marcher et éventuellement cette
nouvelle majorité peut-être plurielle en
tout cas voilà merci à vous d'être venu
en plateau anciens et nouveaux référents
de la république est en marche on se
retrouve bientôt sur tv soixante dix
huit avec un nouvel invité politique
[Musique]